.
>> Todd: IT SEEMS TO GO ONE WAY,
BROOKE SINGMAN, THANK YOU.
HUNTER BIDEN FORMER BUSINESS
PARTNER BOBULINSKI BREAKING HIS
SILENCE ACCUSING HUNTER OF
TAMPERING WITH KEY DOCUMENTS.
WATCH.
>> HUNTER BIDEN HAS NOT BEEN
INDICTED FOR THAT?
>> I AM NOT AWARE OF THAT.
>> THEY WERE SHAFTING YOU?
I DON'T SEE EXPLANATION, DO YOU?
>> I'M SURE YOU CAN GET COMMENT
FROM THE BIDEN FAMILY.
>> THEY ARE NOT RETURNING OUR
CALLS.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA, AUTHOR OF
"COME ON MAN," JOINING US NOW.
TONY BOBULINSKI SPOKE TO TUCKER
CARLSON AND SAID JOE BIDEN IS
THE BIG GUY AND NOW SAYING
HUNTER CHANGED DOCUMENTS AND
FUNNELED MILLIONS INTO HIS OWN
BUSINESS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS?
>> Joe: WHAT IS TRULY AMAZING,
NO OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATION WILL
MENTION THE NAME TONY
BOBULINSKI, LET ALONE WHAT A
FORMER LIEUTENANT OF THE NAVY IS
ALLEGING.
YOU SEE ZERO NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
PICKED UP WHAT BOBULINSKI TOLD
TUCKER CARLSON LAST NIGHT, THAT
IS CALLED BIAS BY OMISSION AND
11th COMMANDMENT, THOU SHALT NOT
REPORT ON ANYTHING HUNTER BIDEN
AND WHAT BOBULINSKI ALLEGED TWO
YEARS AGO THAT 10% OF PROFITS
FROM SHADY DEALS OVERSEAS WENT
TO THE BIG GUY, THE BIG GUY
BEING JOE BIDEN AND THE QUESTION
NOW WHEN THERE IS GOP CONGRESS
AND LOOKS MORE AND MORE LIKE
THAT WILL HAPPEN AFTER THE
MIDTERM, IF THEY TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE, THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THE QUESTION
THEY WILL HAVE, IS HE
COMPROMISED BY TWO COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE NEWS
LATELY, CHINA AND UKRAINE WHERE
THE DEALS TOOK PLACE, SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
TONY BOBULINSKI DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE BOOKED ANYWHERE ELSE TO TALK
THESE DAYS, WHY IS THAT?
>> Todd: WATCH THAT INTERVIEW
TONIGHT 8 P.M. ON TUCKER, FULL
HOUR DEVOTED TO THIS.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP SUING CNN
FOR DEFAM AGSZ FOR CALLING HIM A
RACIST AND COMPARING HIM TO
HITLER.
JOE, YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
LEARNED ABOUT THIS SUIT?
>> THE TRUMP LAWSUIT AGAINST CNN
SAYS THE NETWORK APPLICATION OF
THE BIG LIE HAS NAZI CONNOTATION
AND IT IS NOT LIKE THAT TERM HAS
BEEN ORDERED AND SAID ON THE AIR
A FEW TIMES HERE AND THERE BY
NETWORK ANCHORS AND REPORTERS
AND CORRESPONDENCE, THE BIG LIE
HAS BEEN USED REFERENCE TO TRUMP
7700 TIMES SINCE JANUARY 20 OF
2021 ON CNN.
AND THEY ARE URGING NETWORK
ANCHORS NOT TO USE THE TERM, BUT
THAT PLEA HAS BEEN IGNORED IN
SOME CASES.
IF I WERE CNN, I WOULD BE
CONCERNED, THE TEENAGER FROM
KENTUCKY SUED CNN FOR 275
MILLION AND THEY HAD TO SETTLE,
SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT.
IT'S A BIG NUMBER FOR SURE.
>> Carley: TRUMP SAYS HE WILL
FILE LAWSUITS AGAINST A LARGE
NUMBER OF FAKE NEWS MEDIA
COMPANIES FOR LIES, DEFAMATION
AND WRONGDOING INCLUDING AS
PERTAINS TO THE BIG LIE THAT
THEY USE SO OFTEN IN REFERENCE
TO THEIR DISINFORMATION ATTACK
ON PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION OF
2020.
MORE LAWSUITS TO COME, JOE.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS GOES?
DO YOU THINK THIS IS WORTH THE
PRESIDENT'S TIME?
THIS SEEMS IT COULD BE A HARD
LAWSUIT TO WIN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> Joe: THESE LAWSUITS ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO WIN, YOU ARE RIGHT,
YOU HAVE TO SHOW DAMAGES IN THE
SITUATIONS AND AFTER THE
MIDTERMS, I WOULD IMAGINE YOU
MAY BE HEARING FROM THE
PRESIDENT PROBABLY IN JANUARY OF
2023 WHETHER HE IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT OR NOT.
I WOULD IMAGINE THIS LAWSUIT, IF
STILL GOING ON, IT FOCUSES ON
THE 2020 ELECTION AND HIS
ALLEGATIONS BEING STOLEN AND ANY
CANDIDATE IS BEST SERVED LOOKING
TOWARD THE FUTURE.
LET'S FIX PROBLEMS IF THEY
EXIST, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
INFLATION, CRIME, BORDER,
EDUCATION, LOOKING FORWARD IS
THE BETTER APPROACH IF YOU ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Carley: PICK UP YOUR COPY OF
"COME